-Welcome back.
It is always great to see you.
Michelle, congratulations,
by the way.
Yesterday,
you just got nominated
for a Critic's Choice Award.
-I know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a big deal.
♪♪
-I know. It's such an
illustrious group of actresses.
It's such an honor.
-You crushed it as Betty Ford
in "The First Lady."
Yeah, she was amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was reading up
a little bit about you,
and I saw something
I thought was interesting.
That when you get a role
or a job, that you either
try to get out of it
or try to get fired from it.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that true?
-I mean, sometimes the only way
to get out is to get fired.
-But that's true?
-It's just all --
It's just --
My hands are sweating
as we're even discussing this.
I get performance anxiety.
-You do?
-Yeah, and I do.
And I get --
You know, people are always
so surprised that an actor
would have performance anxiety,
but...
-But you do.
-Yeah.
And I guess they say --
they do say, though,
when that stops,
you should really hang it up.
-Oh.
-That it's sort of part of
the juice that kind of
gets us going.
-Yeah.
Every night I feel like --
"Yeah, I'm not coming out."
-Yeah?
[ Laughter ]
And then I just keep coming out,
yeah.
-You keep coming out.
-I keep coming out.
But every movie?
"Scarface?" Everything?
"Batman Returns"?
-No, no.
I didn't, because I was
obsessed with Catwoman
since I was a little girl.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, actually,
someone was cast before me --
Annette Benning,
who's wonderful.
-Wow.
-And then she got pregnant.
Awesome.
-Yeah.
-And then I got the part!
I got the part!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
You nailed it.
And, you know, congrats on
"The Ant-Man" movies, as well.
Do you like
doing superhero movies?
I think you're
pretty good in them.
-Yeah, I mean, they're kind --
look, they're a mixed bag.
You know, like, the outfits
are always super uncomfortable,
and you forget it's like
childbirth a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
But it's -- you know, "Ant-Man"
is such a fun one to work on.
It's such
a great group of people.
-Great cast.
-And funny and smart.
And it was really fun,
this last one,
because, first one, I wasn't
really in it that much.
I sort of showed up
for a couple weeks
and did my bit and then left.
And I didn't really honestly
get to know them.
But this time,
I was there for the long run.
-Yeah.
Paul Rudd said that
everyone freaked out
at "The Avengers: Endgame,"
the final scene,
when you walked on set.
And they were all sitting there,
like, "Oh, my God.
Michelle Pfeiffer."
-No.
-Yeah, that is definitely true.
He told me, he said that.
-Well, I wasn't aware of that.
I was freaking out.
-You were trying
to get out of it.
You were trying to get fired
from "Avengers: Endgame."
Like, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Do you ever get excited
about meeting anyone?
-I do.
Actually, I was really excited
to work with Jonathan Majors.
He's in "Ant-Man,"
and we have --
A lot of our scenes
are together.
And, you know, it's an
interesting, this one is.
I don't know
what I'm allowed to say.
-Yeah. I know, you're really
not allowed to say much.
-They give you a whole list
of what you can't say
but not anything
what you can say, so...
-Next time you come on,
I want you to bring that list.
[ Laughter ]
I want to read what you --
-And I'll just read it.
-"Here's exactly what
I can't say about the movie."
-Yeah.
-Also, your giant movie career.
You also have
this amazing fragrance line.
Henry Rose.
-I do.
-Congratulations on this.
-Oh, and you happen to have it
back there.
-Oh, yes, I do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I want to talk about this.
'Cause I do like
the packaging, as well.
The packaging is very cool.
Can you see -- You can see
"Henry Rose" through the bottle.
-Yeah.
-Can you see that?
-And how did this come about?
When did this start taking off?
-Well, it started --
Really, the genesis of it
was really around 25 years ago
when I became a new mom.
And I started looking
at the world
through my children's eyes,
like a lot of people do.
And I started paying
closer attention to
what I was exposing them to
and looking at the ingredients
and the things we were putting
on our bodies.
And -- And, you know,
what I discovered is that
fragrance was completely
non-transparent.
It was really the last black box
of transparency.
And so I stopped wearing
fragrance for 10 years.
And I love, obviously --
I love fragrance.
And, um...
-Was it difficult to get off
the ground, or were you like,
"I'm Michelle Pfeiffer,
so let's just do this"?
[ Laughter ]
-No, no.
It was -- I --
So, about 15 years ago, I --
And after trying all kinds of
concoctions on the market,
I really missed that sort of
fine fragrance.
And I decided, "Okay. Well,
I'm gonna see if I can do this.
There must be other people
looking for this product."
And nobody really understood it.
And I think I was just
a little too ahead of the curve.
And so, I --
It's a good thing I'm good
with rejection because,
you know, I'd go out there
and make a go of it
and get rejected,
and I'd, you know,
go with my tail between my legs,
and I'd shelve it for a while,
and then I'd bring it back.
-You kept bringing it back.
-And try again.
And then I'd shelve it
for two years.
And then, finally,
about five years ago,
I thought, "Okay."
It was New Year's Day.
I remember.
I said, "Okay.
What do you want to do
this year?"
"I'm gonna give that fragrance
thing one more try."
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, anyway, 2019 --
So, I finally found --
I found --
I.F.F. was a great partner.
I went directly to -- I bypassed
the cosmetic industry.
I went directly
to the perfume house
and started working
with perfumers.
And in 2019, we launched
with five transformative,
100% transparent fragrances
that really, you know,
disrupted the fragrance market.
And we really
created a new category.
And so, we are the very first
genderless line of
luxury fine fragrances
to have earned
the safety stamp of approval.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's amazing that you did that.
-Yeah.
We launched
just direct to consumer.
And this year,
we've moved into retail.
And people
can go on the website
and use the location finder
to find a store near you.
-Michelle, that's massive.
That's so cool.
-I know, it's very cool.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, I love that.
Do you find,
now that you're doing this now,
do you have a heightened
sense of smell?
-Well...
[ Laughter ]
Little fun fact.
-Yeah.
-I was --
I was at the E.N.T., you know...
-Yeah.
-...getting probed, which is
a really nice experience.
-Ear, nose, and throat, yeah.
-Yeah, and he's looking up --
you know, looking up my nostril,
and he says...
-That's what they do.
-He goes, "Oh. Interesting."
[ Laughter ]
And I said, "What?
What's interesting?"
He goes, "Oh, well,
you have an organ
in your nose..."
-What?
-"...that people
don't usually have."
It's like an organ, right?
-I don't know, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what I would do.
-He said it's called
the vomeronasal organ.
And you find it in mammals,
in animals.
And they really use it
to detect pheromones and mate.
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
Cool.
-And I have this.
-You have it?
-So, I have sort of have
an animalistic
kind of sense of smell, I guess.
-This is perfect then!
See?
-Who knew?
Well, I thought maybe we would
put it to the test
and play a fun game
when we come back.
Are you down with that?
-Yeah, I'm down with that.
But you've practiced that game
a lot, and I haven't.
-I don't practice anything.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I have no idea.
-Yeah, but you live here.
-Are you looking for --
I do live here.
[ Laughter ]
I sleep under this desk.
-I'm looking for a scent --
-Are you looking
for a scent for me?
-Yeah, I want to try it on you.
This one.
-How do I put it on --
Can I ask how I -- How do I --
-You want to do
the dolphin thing?
-Yeah.
-All right.
-I kind of dive into it.
You spray it, and I'll
dolphin my way through it.
-Okay. You ready?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
Wait.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
Ooh, that's fun!
Yeah!
Oh, I'm feeling it!
Now I got it now, too!
I love it!
Michelle Pfeiffer and I
are playing a new game
after the break! Stick around!